ينتخب الرئيس في النظام الرئاسي التركي
مباشره من الشعب لعهده مدتها خمس سنوات
ولا يمكن للبرلمان عزله من منصبه قبل
نهايه فتره ولايته ويجري التصويت في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه في جوله اولى تتطلب
حصول المرشح على اكثر من 50% من الاصوات
للفوز والا يمر السباق الى جوله ثانيه
يتنافس فيها المرشحان الفائزان باكبر عدد
من الاصوات في الجوله الاولى
ويمكن لاي حزب فاز بنسبه خمسه في المئه من
الاصوات وهي العتبه الانتخابيه في
الانتخابات البرلمانيه السابقه تقديم مرشح
للانتخابات الرئاسيه اما المستقلون فيتعين
عليهم جمع مئه الف توقيع من الناخبين
المسجلين من اجل الترشح في الانتخابات
البرلمانيه يصوت الناخبون لاختيار 600
نائب في مجلس الامه التركي الكبير وحتى
يفوز حزب ما بالاغلبيه البرلمانيه يتعين
عليه الح
اكبر عدد من الاصوات وهي فعاله في تسهيل
تشكيل الاغلبيه البرلمانيه يقلل ذلك اهميه
التحالفات بالنسبه للاحزاب الصغيره اذ
اضحى حصولها على مقاعد في البرلمان
رهنا بعدد الاصوات التي يحصل عليها كل حزب
على حده لا على الاصوات التي يفوز بها
مجمل التحالف كما كان سابقا وما قد يجعل
الانتخابات البرلمانيه اكثر اهميه هي
المنافسه الشرسه المتوقعه بين التحالفات
لا سيما وان الهدف الرئيسي لتحالف
المعارضه الاكبر هو العوده بالبلاد الى
النظام البرلماني وذاك امر يحتاج لعرضه
على استفتاء شعبي وهو ما لن يتم الا
بتصويت ثلثي مقاعد البرلمان او نسبه 60%
على الاقل من النواب